G20 leaders have held an emergency
meeting after an explosion in Poland
which Ukraine is blaming on Russian
missiles the U.S President Joe Biden
says it's unlikely that Moscow is
responsible for the blast but he has
promised to support an investigation two
people were killed in the explosion in a
village near the Ukrainian border Alex
Baird has more
scenes that have become all too common
in Ukraine now in neighboring Poland two
missiles are believed to have hit
Farmland around 10 kilometers from the
Ukrainian border two farmers were killed
all day today Russia was attacking
Ukraine with rockets but we do not have
any conclusive evidence at the moment as
to who launched this missile the
investigation is underway I deeply
believe the investigators will clarify
that it was most likely a russian-made
missile but this is all still under
investigation
but across the border in Ukraine
President Vladimir zielinski was quick
to blame the Kremlin
firing missiles at NATO territory as a
Russian attack on collective security
this is a very significant escalation we
must act I want to say now to all our
polish brothers and sisters Ukraine will
always support you three people will not
be broken by Terror
Russia has denied it was involved in a
statement its defense Ministry said that
statements by polish media and officials
about Russian missiles hissing polish
territory are a deliberate provocation
with the aim of escalating the situation
the U.S state department has been
careful not to jump to conclusions we
have seen reports out of Poland they of
course are incredibly concerning and
we're working with our partners in the
public government and our NATO Partners
to get more information and to assess
what has happened NATO allies have been
quick to Rally behind Warsaw as the
alliance Works to establish what
actually happened a number of
neighboring countries held emergency
security meetings others renewed their
pledges to defend every inch of NATO
territory Poland has not yet announced
how it will react but it's not taking
any chances
we decided a moment ago to increase the
Readiness of some military units in
Poland and increase the Readiness of
other uniform services in our country
all eyes are now on NATO as it grapples
with house respond and house will void a
dangerous escalation to the war in
Ukraine Alex beard Al Jazeera
our diplomatic editor James Bays is
joining us now from the G20 Summit in
Bali where the leaders have been
discussing the explosion James I know
that there has been a lot of a very
intensive discussion and talks in the
aftermath of this just talk us through
what's been happening
yeah well President Biden we know was
woken around Dawn to be told of this and
very soon after that he made a phone
call to president Duda of Poland
expressing his support after these
missile killed two people and he's had
meetings he's had meetings with all of
the G7 countries they were joined by two
NATO members Spain and the Netherlands
and also the top officials of the
European Union who normally sit in any
way on G7 meetings but since that
meeting President Biden has been
speaking again of the latest information
the U.S has and he says there's
preliminary information that contests
the fact that Russia fired this missile
that was fired from Russia I don't want
to say that until we completely
investigate and he went on it's unlikely
from the trajectory that it was fired
from Russia but we'll see uh president
Duda of Poland has also said after a
national security meeting there there's
no equivocal evidence of who fired the
missile so there is a considerable doubt
here whether it definitely was a Russia
that was responsible clearly if Russia
was responsible then that creates a very
very serious uh situation it might be
worth telling you what one prominent
Russian is saying uh the deputy
Ambassador at the United Nations Dimitri
poliansky I advise everyone to look at
the facts before Russian to conclusion
it's obvious from the impact that of the
direct rocket strikes would be
significantly bigger than the pictures
show so the Russians pouring doubt on
this so are many of the others
other countries and
urging a full investigation Poland now
saying that other countries will help
them in the investigation this will
continue to be subject to discussion I
think here at the G20 because so many of
the leaders are in the same place in
fact you can see the pictures now
they're all dressed in white the leaders
they've just been out to plant mangroves
as part of a climate initiative of the
G20 but I'm sure as they're walking
along in the very hot temperatures there
president mackerel Chancellor Schultz
President Biden and the others will be
discussing uh the situation and what has
happened in Poland ahead of the next
important diplomatic event which is the
meeting of NATO ambassadors which will
take place in Brussels as they decide
what their next steps should be
obviously James we're going to be
talking to you again as the G20 meeting
continues and and so on and especially
with the aftermath of the explosion for
now James thank you very much indeed